début d'émission, il y avait des
extraitse e gens qui tenaient
des propos extrêmes.
- C't t essentiel qu'on entend
ces gens-là, parce que si on ne
va pas les voir que si on essaye
pas de comprendre ce qui les
anime, je pense qu'on manque
complètement le bateau niveau de
la couverture, c'est une
proportion importante de la
population américaine qui pense
qu'effectivement
n'est pas grave, l'avortement,
ce n'est pas notre problème. Les
armes à feu, ils vont avoir
davantage parce que ça prend
toujours pour se défendre.tttttt
important de noter, c'est toute
cette espèce de... et surtout
des extrémistes aussi et on est
o o o o o o o o o o o o o o o e
polarisation qui vraiment anime
ces gens, et notre rôle à nous,
différentes pensées, mais
ultimement, journaliste, si on
me dit qu'il y a 1000 soleils
dortauauauautre me dit qu'il
pleut des cordes, moi, mon rôle,
c'est de sortir par la fenêtre,
de regarder, je m'excuse, il
quand même mettre ça en
perspective, en prenant le pouls
aiaiaiaint-Jean, on n'est pas là
pour la faire changer d'opinion,
c'est pas possible, sont comme
ça, parfois il y a
l'endoctrinement, parfois c'est
des moments très bien organisés.
- collllllllllllllllllllllllllls
médias, comment ils vous voient?
- Depuis 2016, cordes trop
hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahs
vannes justement qu't t t t dire
n'importe quoi et faire
n'importe quoi, vous êtes
l'ennemi du peananananand on va
sur le terrain, des convois une
caméra, ils disent qu'on est des
fake news, etc., c'est ce qu'on
l'entend tout le temps, mais on
fait notre travail, on peut vous
pa v v v v va vous écouter mes
arrêtés de partir du principe
qu'on va forcément mentir.
- Il y a vraiment une
radicalisation que nous, quand
on fait des sujets comme
l'avortement, la religion entre
en compte, souvent de ces très
émotif, tu peux pas raisonner,
mais je pense que le public dans
le reportage que l'on est obligé
d'équilibrer les opinions, il
faut montrer les opinions,
le public est capable de
faire... on avait dit qu'on
était de CBC, les ge
qu'on était une organisme
chrétien, mais on a rien dit.
- C'est incroyable, on disait
qu'on s'en sortirait pas son
Dieu, il y a quand même de
l'idéologie là-dedans. Ce qui
ces villes aux États-Unis, la
montée du populisme que çat t te
travailler, mais c'est
contagieux, comment ça se vit
comme sur le terrain, Raphaël?
- J'ai été aux États-Unis il y a
quelques années pendant
justement la présidence de
Donald Trump, où j'ai couvert
plusieurs de ces rassemblements.
Je dois dire aussi que quand
même que quand les Canadiens, on
a un accès sans être
représentant de la corporation
chrétienne, les gens sont
ouverts à nous parler parce que
cette polarisation est beaucoup
au niveau des médias américains,
c'est peut-être un peu moins le
quart à l'endrosssssss
canadiens, c'est un avantage
dont on dispose sur le terrain.
Je suis en Europe maintenant, et
on voit cette polarisation qui
existe aussi dans les sociétés
européennes.
- La montée du populisme,
- J'ai été et en Hongrie pour
couvrir la réélection de Victor,
le sentiment, c'était un peu den
rassemblement de Donald Trump,
il y avait beaucoup de
similitudes dans le type de
propos qu'on entendait,
d'ailleurs que tu n'as pas été
très favorable représentant de
médias canadiens parce que
quelqu'un ne pas beaucoup le
Canada et ses politiques et est
venu me le dire, on voit cette
division, on les voit aill
en Europe. René le Royaume-Uni,
où le débat sur le breaks était
toujours présent et...
on commence à avoir légué bouger
un peu. Mais il y a des
discussions qui sont parfois des
discussions de sons, de gens qui
ne s'entendent pas sur cette
question du Brexit, se compose
États-Unis entre démocrates et
républicains. Si on ne parle pas
enenenenenenenenenent le Brésil,
comment on peut voir venir ce
mouvement qui finalement s'est
concrétisé, c'est
essentiellement que je pense.
- J'ai couvert un sujet qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la
situation aux États-Unis ou en
Europe, j'ai été sur une petite
île, l'archipel auprès de la
Chine qui appartient... qui esïn
voulait démontrer que ce n'est
pas blanc ou noir, cette tension
entre la Chine et Taiwan
des gens qui ont des
attachements à la chaîne même
s'ils sont taïwanais. Il y a des
gens qui ont vu le reportage et
on est dans cet esprit de
polarisation où tout doit être
d'un côté ou de
On me reproche d'avoir été trop
nuancé, d'avoir admis qu'en
fait, il y a
situation, plus qu'une vérité
dans ce cas, donc c'est vraiment
l'état d'esprit dans lequel on
est de façon générale, les gens
qui me lgegegegegegegegegegegens
qui venaient d'ici le du Canada,
qui avait vu le reportage.
- Tout le monde est un peu
étourdi, je conclurai simplement
en rappelant que notre rôle àair
les gens à qui on parle mais der
refléter ses idées parce
qu'elles existent, ça ne sert à
rien de se mettre la tête dans
le sable. Je pense qu'on offre
un portrait beaucoup plus
complet de ce qui se passe
autour de nous quand on donne ls
nécessairement cautionner leupun
n'est pas dire que c'est bien ou
pas, mais il faut permettre à
ses idées être transmis aussi,
on ne peut pas vivre en vase
clos avec des gens qui nous
ressemblent en tout point pense.
- C'est pas parce qu'on les
diffuse qu'on est d'accord. Dans
le cas de la Russie, A
quand la guerre s'est
déclenchée, regarder quelqu'un
dans les yeux qui nous dit :
tant mieux, on va aller
finalement ce procédé nazi en
Ukraine. C'est dur à entendre.
On connaît les vérités, mais on
n'est pas là pour juger, on est
là pour écouter le que c'est
imeseseseseseseseseseseseses
gens existent, dans le cas de la
Russie, on vit dans un monde de
propagande que ce n'est pas
l'expression, c'est la règle, si
on ne comprend pas les gens qui
nous entourent, on ne peut pasol
faut.
- Aux États-Unis, ce qui est c s
réseaux de télévision, Fox News
contre CNN, quand vous écoutez
Fox News, qui part du grand
remplacement, que les États-Unis
vont être envahis par les
migrants, les gens finissent par
se radicaliser, il y a
énormément de mensonges qui sont
diffusés à la télévision et ça
radicalise une partie de la
population. Je pense qu'il y a
un rôle des médias aussi sur
toutes ces radicalisatiopopulaùn
dit qu'on était
nous aimait bien, il nous disait
: vous avez vos camionneurs
canadiens, bravo!
- Est-ce que les gens vous
perçoivent comme des méchants
socialis
le prolongement de la politique
canadienne?
- On le perçoit évidemment à
travers les réseaux sociaux, les
énormes commentaires qu'on
reçoit souvent, énormément,
ce qui est ce qui est
l'ex- station de la
polarisation que c'est comme si
les personnes qui nous suiventvs
e-mails, des messages sur les
réseaux sociaux, c'est comme si
c'était un perroquet de ce qu'on
entend aux États-Unis, c'est
toujours un peu les mêmes termes
qui reviennent et qui... c'estet
ce qui est quand même
incroyable, parfois inquiée e ez
violent aussi et dondire, l'idét
ne pas engagé parce qu'on n'est
pas là pour les convaincre de
quoi que ce soit, ces gens-là en
général ne cha
et con
justement ceux qui pensent être
la vérité et au fur et à mesure
de répéter leurs mensonges ou
les faussetés qu'il comporte, il
pense que ça dev